Harry Jack nation Greg Alda here John a
happy Monday first off wanted to talk
about something that's really exciting
stuff right here we don't really talk
about box office results ever but this
was something that I've been reading up
on that I found very compelling Black
Panther has top six hundred million
dollars domestically it is the third
movie in the last 19 years to top number
one at the box office in America for
five weeks in a row
take that Jumanji as of today it's only
a few million dollars away from
surpassing Avengers in the box office in
terms of domestic it looks like it's
gonna be on track to become the highest
grossing superhero movie of all time in
America which is crazy yeah we all knew
Black Panther will be a hit we knew this
would be a big factor in like cultural
phenomenon I think the bar was set a
little bit lower in terms of just how
insanely well it would do it seems to be
surprising people how wow yeah like it
is dominating it is doing crazy numbers
and breaking crazy records left and
right and yeah like I think yeah we all
knew it was gonna be big but it just
keeps on growing
and what's crazy is is Black Panther is
gonna get killed off in infinity war I
know which is gnarly after you think
they want to keep him around for more
sequels this is crazy this is great news
because it's already well surpassed age
of Ultron in terms of domestic box
office and I'm so happy for the film
there's been a lot of talk about you
know like the first major black
superhero yes see there was blade there
was spawn in terms of like the the wild
phase we've had a superhero movies over
the past decade the MCU DC you all these
the superhero phenomenon that we've got
and black panther being the first
African superhero to be a part of this
wide phenomenon it is so cool to know
just how dominating it is baby the
second time I watched black panther and
there was a really nice moment that I
was able to witness when the movie was
done there's this black family that was
in the theater there's like several kids
and they were rocking Black Panther
shirts and then when the movie was done
that the mom had the kids stand in front
of the screen and take a photo I never
see families ever do that for any movie
ever is a huge thing yeah as much talk
as I've heard on the Internet
and and in circles of people talking
about cultural phenomenon it was that
moment right there where it really hit
me to be witness to something like that
to watch a black family be so proud of
this movie that they had to take a
picture in front of the screen with
their kids just to be like we saw Black
Panther this was a magical day and I'm
never gonna forget this moment I'm just
so happy to be here I'm really thrilled
for this movie I'm excited for the
entire cast Ryan Coogler Clayton just do
whatever he wants forever this is third
feature film and it is like destroy
what's gnarly to me - about this Black
Panther experience is infinity war comes
out in them like a month and like a week
or something what's crazy is Black
Panthers still gonna be playing in
theaters most likely Oh wouldn't have
Finity war yeah like people are probably
gonna do a double feature there's just I
go to back there they don't need to do
like a hard blu-ray release to get you
excited for because I'm sure that's what
the original plan was yeah it was
released black panther then get it on
blu-ray to get people reject up for
infinity war to get the next time for
the next film but this will be the
probably the first time in MCU history
this film is still gonna be performing
pretty well if the box up and it's in it
and then his Black Panthers are gonna be
in two movies at once playing at your
theaters it's crazy to me and then
they're gonna package of that DVD
release to hype of ant-man the wasp yeah
oh man like two black panthers you could
you could have literally do a double
vision of double T'Challa action and it
would probably work out with black
panther topping the box office - I find
it fascinating how they're not really
putting black panther that front and
center on the Infinity war trailers you
know it's like I feel like we're getting
a lot more looks at other characters
more than Black Panther like you see him
in the trailers of course
like we see what condom more than black
pants yeah and you think with like black
panther killing it right now they get
way more of that but it also makes me
wonder how they're good the success of
this if they're gonna have managed if
they're gonna work a little bit on on
reworking the follow-up to infinity war
whatever the part to is to have more
black panther in there because you
better believe that we're gonna get a
lot more black panther now we love the
movie I saw it twice already I think
it's a fantastic film I'm just really
happy that this film is doing so well so
it's one of those films yeah you know
definitely I think a lot of movies and
every now and again they make a film and
that one's that one's a film you excited
for black panther are you gonna do a
double feature the theaters are you
gonna do a marathon of all 18 plus
infinity war all 19 Marvel movies free
yeah subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell get notified
every time when our vids is up and you
guys can check us out on patreon weekly
Q&A is over there as well as full-length
TV show reactions and stuff like attack
on Titan just started Jessica Jones John
Cobb covers Marvel's runaways in
Riverdale I'm catching up on the flash
and and so you're just a bunch of stuff
so go check us out there